i would probably give two pieces of
advice one is take a long view
take a long view of your business and
take a long view of your relationships
with
investors with co-founders with
employees
even with customers
[Music]
gil dibner thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders we're finally
here and i'm so excited to do this with
you
thank you thanks michael i have to say
that just going over the companies that
you invested in i
i am a huge fan of probably half of them
and and i think that it tells a lot
about about your outlook on investments
and how you approach
uh different and different environments
in different industries and one of the
things that that took me
and i took a note on when i read your
bio is this idea that you're you're
working to build category leaders
so even before we talk about you and
your life
what is a category leader and why is
that sort of the mindset that you bring
to investments
i mean i think there was a time you know
you know a few minutes ago when saying
category leader was like uh
you know still sort of a unique thing
that some vcs said and i think now all
vcs are saying this
um but i think the reason they use that
term
i i think it sort of indicates two
things i think the first thing is it
suggests that you want a really large
outcome
and right what so you know you want to
be a leader in a category you want to
define the category and lead that
category and
i think that's an indication of scale i
think another reason that people use
that
term is because
successful founders i think successful
venture capitalists
or strategists in general you you
thinking about the way
the the world of business and technology
kind of organizes itself and i think i i
literally just had this conversation
with a founder like an hour ago
where they are you know competing for
you know cloud management infrastructure
as code blah blah blah
and at one point the conversation i was
like look i don't really understand
what your thesis is there is a huge
gaping problem
in the cloud infrastructure management
infrastructures code world
but there are like 250 startups
that i know about if i went through the
process of listing them all which i
would never
do that like you know that i can't keep
track of them all they're all
rushing into that void trying to solve
that pain so the argument of the pain is
not important but
what will happen over time is that
they'll all converge they'll all
eventually over the next five ten years
it'll become obvious what that category
is and what how one wins in that
category
and i think what is important for
founders even at the earliest stages is
to try to have some kind of a thesis
about
how do you think your category is going
to evolve what do you think are going to
be the driving
you know forces that are going to make
you make a company successful what is
the leader in that category going to
look like
and then what are we doing today that
gets us there right and i think that
framing is is sort of helpful to remind
ourselves and founders of that's what
we're trying to do here
we're we're feeling our way through the
dark to try to define categories
by the way sometimes if you're not
defining a new category you're just
displacing an existing one with
something far better
but it's important to know what the
playing field is right but also as an
early stage investor
it's not like you're talking to
companies that have years of
of experience necessarily with working
on their product
and some you know um genius insight that
they have above other people so how do
you actually go about
finding those right people that could
potentially become category leaders as
people not just as their product
well i mean first of all sometimes they
do right now there's sometimes
you know we've been lucky to back you
know one or two second time founders you
know notably eldad farquhar should fire
both where we're thrilled to back him
the second time after
after he's built sci-sense but um
in many cases we have founders that have
tremendous domain expertise
in other words they understand okay they
haven't built a software company to
dominate the category but they
understand
their industry supremely well and i
think that deep domain expertise is a
huge
a huge issue a huge secret weapon for a
lot of these companies
um you're absolutely right a lot of
times the company building skills
are new to people they don't necessarily
know how to manage people they don't
necessarily know how to recruit people
they don't necessarily
know how to strategize about product
strategy or even how to hire a product
manager or what that looks like
but they often understand they often
have an insight on a category
you know not to overuse that word but
they have an insight on a on a space
to say hey you know we have a company
for example oil and gas and the ceo of
that company worked in the oil and gas
industry for
you know many many years and understands
it super well and
was like hey i have a i have a vision
for how this is going to emerge
and i've been a customer of all of the
terrible software tools that exist
and i've been suffering about this for
years and i have a vision for what it
would have to look like to
to succeed and so i'm going to build a
company based on that set of insights
and so
you know we do try to filter for that
kind of thing so
a beautiful segue talking about oil and
gas i have to take you all the way back
to your to your college days you're
working in an oil tanker in the gulf of
mexico what was that about
oil and gas no i mean it was uh my dad
uh is a maritime guy uh he was a
business consultant of the maritime
industry for many years
and um his father had sent him to work
as a construction worker in high school
in the summer to understand what real
work was and
uh you know my my dad wanted me to have
a real work experience as well
and and so in the summer of my freshman
year
after my freshman year he suggested to
me that instead of taking some
internships somewhere
where i could put in a student tie and
pretend to do something i could go work
on oil tanker and
he knew uh the guy who ran this company
because it was one of his clients
hey would you put my son on an
asphalt tanker actually it was called an
ordinary semen like the most junior
role possible and uh asphalt has to be
heated i don't know if you know this but
asphalt will freeze if it's not heated
so caribbean sun middle of the summer on
a
600 foot heated container a
heated oil tanker effectively that was
carrying asphalt that was stinky and
horrible was fantastic the best time my
life and
nothing since then has felt like work um
so it's it was it was an education
probably a very different experience
than what a lot of your fellow harvard
classmates
experienced that time i was super proud
of myself i thought i had discovered the
secret to life i was gonna be the next
hemingway that was my plan
i love it so so gil walk me through a
little bit of your journey you're you're
going to harvard you're studying
economics then you go to wharton
and do you know that you're destined to
support early-stage entrepreneurs along
their career
um i mean i i think i'm probably the
most boring vc story of anyone i
i wrote my college admission essay about
how i wanted to be a vc in israel when i
was 18.
so really i think i pretty much had this
figured out i don't
know where i can't find a copy of it but
i know i did write it and
i i think it had to do with i i
i really liked the idea of innovation
and technology
um and i sort of had figured out that i
was not smart enough to do this
innovation myself
so i was like okay well the closest i
can get is i gotta find some way to have
these people want to hang out with me
so um you know the business seemed like
a
you know logical way to do that um and
i uh you know i gotta give my dad credit
as well i think there was a point in my
life when i thought i wanted to be an
engineer and my dad who was trained as
an engineer but was always a business
guy
said you know you know i'm all for you
studying stem but i think you know it's
actually
you know the business world is actually
where a lot of these decisions get made
and you should
you should look at that as well and so
that kind of led me down the economics
path and i thought that was
fascinating that being said about 10
minutes ago we were having an
interesting conversation about deep
neural networks and how
different companies are doing their
interesting things with them so
obviously you're still an engineer at
heart and you have that and you have
that
and that skill set but how do you then
go on to actually becoming an investor
because i think that one of the things
that i
that i enjoy most hearing about this
show is you know the journey of people
and how they take that passion i have
yet to make to meet somebody who wrote
their college admission essay
on wanting to be a vc but how do you
then translate that
interest going through harvard wharton
and then translating it to working with
the israeli and european ecosystem and
i'd also love to know why why
specifically that ecosystem
well i think you know the israel thing
for me was always a goal i i'd always
wanted to live in israel i
i still want to live in israel it's the
place i feel most at home
it's my identity my mother's israeli i
grew up in both countries
i love israel i think it's the most
special
place in the world for a million reasons
it has many problems and challenges and
troubles but
you know uh so do many places um
but i think um i i just got lucky with a
series of experiences that exposed me to
the israeli technology world you know
fairly early
um and um uh
i just fell in love with with with that
scene and with
with the brilliance and the you know i
think that there was a
you know i i was exposed to the israeli
technology scene as
early as you know my my last college
internship so so
you know 1998 when it really was a
backwater it really was
flying against the tide and no one
really thought
you know there were three places in the
world you could maybe four places in the
world you could build a semiconductor
russia
route 128 corridor in boston silicon
valley and tel aviv that was it
and that was the center of the
technology world and israel was kind of
this island of amazing innovation when
nobody was thinking about technology
nobody cared and was paying any
attention to it
unbelievable and so um the um
[Music]
uh um uh
you know that that was just very
exciting to be
to be part of that i think the
the goal was to to be part of the
israeli technology landscape
but i think when i got there what i
pretty quickly realized
was that i was suddenly found myself an
outsider on
like i had a whole bunch of advantages
right i came to israel with an american
college education right i think just
that gave me a whole bunch of
credibility with
people that hired me i think i think
they hired me because hey look at least
his college logos will look good in our
fundraising deck right even if he's an
idiot at least
we can put the wharton logo on the thing
right but i think
what i quickly realized was that like i
really was an idiot as i
these people were super smart and they
were dealing with stuff that was
incredibly complicated and the
the the the the years of technology
engineering experience
around the table every sunday when we
would review the deals at genesis and
hmna
you had 150 years of engineering
experience around the table and that was
just the people who worked at the firm
right
and i had like zero years of anything
and
you know just watching them listening to
them go through this was incredibly
humbling
and the shared fascination
with innovation with founders that were
pushing the boundaries in a bunch of
ways
and the skill set of sort of uncovering
the truth i think that
was the other lesson from wall street as
well where i worked in
covering technology stocks in the bubble
and you know you had to get the truth
pretty quickly because
the bubble was bursting around us and
right that's a whole nother story for
another episode but
but i think um being an outsider in the
sense that
i i i speak fluent hebrew but certainly
not at that point not about technology
today i do but then i didn't i didn't
have a technical degree i didn't
serve in the army in any of these
technical units i didn't serve in the
army at all i hadn't gone to high school
with any of these people
i didn't share a lot of the same
cultural references
i was really an outsider like on a
million different levels
yeah you leveraged that as an asset
right because i think i
turned it into a bit of an asset in
certain cases where
there might have been some group think
around the table you know the founder is
a pilot and the vc is a pilot and pilots
invest in pilots because
and i was like you know i'm nothing i'm
just like
you know but so learning to judge
founders and to judge their credibility
and to
participate in some but to be a fly on
the wall i should say
on in some very deep technical diligence
when you're really
you know i'll i'll never forget for
example i was doing technical i was
doing technical diligence on a on a tech
company with a
with a with a very senior very
experienced
russian immigrant to israel who was a
very very senior cto and he was
interviewing this israeli
you know cto and you know the israeli
obviously fluent hebrew the russian guy
like strong russian accent but super
super strong
and sorry super super smart and and at
some point he just sort of
stopped questioning and and was like
okay thank you and i asked him
why did you stop and he was like because
i realized he didn't know any of the
answers
and i was like you see the level of like
depth and i think that that was always
something to aspire to
and then the level of like like learning
to really listen to some of these
founders to sort of understand
what was motivating them what was the
technical insight that was driving them
to spend the next 10 years of their life
and i think it also is a very different
environment in the sense that today
you know for better for worse the
default is everyone gets funded right
that that's the default if you're
halfway credible
and you went to stanford no offense
you'll get funded someone's going to
give you money to go build something and
spend three years of your life building
it then the default was no one got
funded like it's just
not gonna work right um and if you got
an a round there's no way in hell you're
getting a b round it just not happening
right so it was a very so so being a
founder back then
in 2004 2005 2006 when there was
literally no money
these people were crazy like these
people were seriously committed to what
they were doing they were really
passionate about building something from
nothing in their
in their domain and you know you you
remember probably israeli tech back in
those days was
all hardcore tech it was like security
and com tech semis and
you know specialty semiconductor and
photovoltaic stuff and like it was
hardcore honestly i wish i was there i
was i was probably about nine years old
at that time but but
but i i definitely think that i could
have i could have fit well yeah but you
remember the scitex logo on the highway
and stuff like that right so
definitely definitely a gil you know so
today you're navigating a different
world you you have both the navigation
back then
today like you're mentioning it's a
different ball game right i mean a lot
of people
having an easier time getting
investments there's a lot more money
floating around the world is becoming
more globalized and you have investors
from different regions investing you're
sitting in london investing primarily in
israel
talk to me a little bit about exactly
that you're sitting in london you have
the european ecosystem as a strength you
have the israeli mindset and the
expertise is the strength how do you
then bring angular angular ventures to
provide that that value both to founders
and how do you even go and identify
those right ones that you want to invest
in
uh this is a 20-minute show right so
sorry like i don't know if i can
answer i don't have to answer half of
that but i think
uh first of all just for clarity we
invest agnostically across europe and
israel
and and the result of that is that we're
about 50 percent europe israel
um half and half um
you know uh how we provide value as a
firm i think is
is comes from the roots of
being being specialists um being nimble
we have a very strong network
you know what we're trying to do as a
firm is is i think relatively unique in
the sense that we are
you know we're specialists we're highly
concentrated we're only going to do
six to eight deals a year right we're
looking at
you know last quarter alone we saw eight
hundred deals
right 814 deals in the past 90 days i
just happened to look at this this
morning right
wow and i think we did one right so like
we're we're doing you know very very
very selective
deal making on a very large pool and
we're narrowing that down super
efficiently we have a wonderful network
of people that are close to us that help
us with diligence
um and what we try to do is we're
actually you know i think of almost like
you know microservices as the analogy
you sort of take in the value chain of
the vc world and try to like
microservice it and then those are what
we call advisory partners or venture
partners so for example fred simon
from jfrog eldad farkas from science and
fireball
our venture partners jerry disler runs
product that google is a venture advisor
jen scheer for example who's the best us
immigration attorney on the planet
is a venture advisor meaning when our
companies have a us immigration issue
and this actually came up like this
morning i you know one of our founders
wants to hire someone
and she doesn't want to get hired unless
she can move and
so jen is now involved in that process
to make sure that we've got the visa
issue sorted out like
those are very advertised discrete
sort of okay it's a service we can call
on to provide value to a founder
um another example was the founders like
hey i've got this huge rfq
right for a deal that's like sits 20
times larger than any deal i've had so
far in my company how do i answer this
quote
how do i price it what do i do you know
he's a finnish founder within 48 hours
we had
set up two hour long calls with two
different advisory partners who were
experts in sales operations
to get him like real-time answers to a
real use case right now and so
what you know a lot of funds have like a
bunch of headshots
of people that are sort of in their
network i've got the secretary of
homeland security
like we have like you know we have
people that are not necessarily the most
famous people in the universe but
they're people that i know i've worked
with them for years i know they can
deliver value
they're highly incentivized they're
highly aligned and
they can actually deliver that value in
real time in a meaningful way and i
think that has a huge impact
so forgive me for my language but then
it boils down to getting done right
it's at the end
it's executing when when you actually
need tangible help it's and especially
in the early stage days you know
it it's it's invaluable and and i think
that those specific examples that you're
mentioning those are exactly the types
of things that i would
honestly that i would be looking for in
a fund that that i would want to partner
with because at the end of the day
it's that partnership and i think that
what i've been understanding throughout
this show is that
that's also part of the dynamic that's
been changing over the past years with
venture capital it's becoming more of a
partnership less of a
you know a financial body that gives you
this you know great loan and great
at great terms but it's really about the
partnership and you're really adding on
more people to your
organization but gil we have very very
little time left i have to ask you for
you know two or three nuggets
from from seeing you know thousands of
deals to to myself
and fellow young entrepreneurs that are
starting their journey or on their
journey
what are some really critical things to
keep in mind as we as we move forward
geez uh i think that that i think that
wins the prize for the most broad
question imagine i could literally
answer anything and it would work
i i like i i i think um
i would i would i would probably give
two pieces of advice one is
take a long view take a long view of
your
business and take a long view of your
relationships with
investors with co-founders with
employees
even with customers that's
i think a super important perspective
that a lot of founders particularly in
today's climate
are missing out on there are
you know i i'd like to paraphrase
churchill i think never before in the
history of finance
has so much money have so much venture
money been just
been distributed so quickly by so many
people so little experience
right um there are funds that didn't
exist
last year with associates writing 10
million dollar series hx into
pre-revenue company now sometimes that's
going to work sometimes there's some
brilliant insight there or some
relationship that enables that to happen
a lot of times there isn't and a lot of
times that associate two years from now
he's gonna be a partner in some other
firm and you're gonna be an orphan
and i think that there's a there's and
that's true with co-founders that's true
with employees it's with a lot of things
i think take a long-term view on the
relationships you're building
on your product strategy going back to
category all that stuff
i think the second thing i would say you
know and it absolutely it's like talking
my book but
i think it's true is i think being
intellectually honest with yourself
and having real intellectual intimacy
with your
investors um not to of course with your
co-founders but certainly with your
investors as well um
about what is it that we're here to do
what is
how much money do we how much money do
we really need what is really unique
about our
company um you know what is what do we
know what do we not know
right um how are we gonna de-risk this
thing um
those are things i think are often
getting forgotten in the
quest to i think a lot of founders are
simply they they can smell the blood in
the water they know that
the pendulum is on their side they know
there's always going to be someone give
writing the terms at a higher price
um and it is almost easier to raise
money with nothing than with something
because if you've got something people
start judging you if you've got nothing
you've just got stories you can you can
raise a ton of money
and i think that that can become a
treadmill to destruction
very very quickly actually um unless
people are really
honest with themselves and with each
other about what are we trying to do
here what do we know what do we not know
and the going gets rough very quickly
whether you raise 20 million or whether
you raise two
it eventually gets rough and so you want
to surround yourself with people that
understand why you're doing it and where
you have a shared
set of values and set of objectives gil
i'm i'm leaving here with the
intellectual
intimacy i i i love that phrase and i'm
sorry but i'm gonna steal it from time
to time because i think that
it just says exactly what i've been
thinking for so long and i've been
pondering myself what type of company
will i want to start in what type of
relationships do i want to build and i
think it boils down to
intellectual intimacy and having that
shared foundation for for partnerships
so thank you for that
gil before we leave i have to ask you
the the hardest question and this one
it's less vague but it's more specific
three words
that you would use to describe yourself
uh i i think uh
uh you know
intellectual honesty let's say that's
one word
resiliency i i think i'm pretty
resilient
and i think i'm pretty relentless i
think what what founders notice when
they
work with me is that uh
when i'm out there fighting for them i'm
not going to give up and i think they
see that
and i think when i disagree with them
about something
or feel i need to call their attention
to something i'm
not going to sugarcoat it or
or wait until the next board meeting
because you deserve to know what i think
today you can disagree with me and go do
something else but like you
what you do what you what i owe you is
my honest
opinion based on what you're telling me
today i reserve the right to change my
mind in three seconds but
i i think when it's a popularity contest
it it's very destructive it's it's
actually not helpful it's much better to
argue and i think that's one of the
things i learned in israeli venture
where they would just argue all day long
and it was amazing because you knew you
heard every opinion in the room you knew
where everybody stood there was no
mystery
and then the founders would go off and
decide what they thought and they would
go do what they wanted to do
and then next board meeting the vcs
would come and yell at them again and
they would say no i'm doing it my way
and
that's fine and then sometimes if you
say oh no i was wrong you were right and
sometimes the other way around but at
least you get everything out i think
that's super important i think when
people are too focused on making
everything seamless right
right it it you're you're losing the
benefit of having the
perspectives in the room anyway i
completely agree and it brings you back
a few years ago reading
outliers by malcolm gladwell talking
about uh the
flight crashes and boiling it down to
being willing to have that controversy
in the room in the cockpit
regardless of ranks when the going gets
tough you say your mind and
and you have an open conversation right
otherwise the plane goes down so gil
thank you very very much this was just
insightful and wonderful thank you for
being so generous
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
you too thank you